I had no idea that Netflix was in my house
in my room.
This is insane.
Meet Chet.
He's a ten year old kid from Brooklyn,
New York.
We heard Chet is a huge One Piece fan.
My son is obsessed with One Piece.
I'm wondering if there's anything
you guys can do to solidify him
as being, like, the number one
One Piece fan.
We decided to surprise him with a total
room makeover.
I think just being so immersed in it,
he probably would turn his room
into a One Piece room,
one way, shape or form.
For two months, our team worked on designing
the One Piece room of Chet's dreams.
It included custom
One Piece wallpaper, a captain's quarters,
tons of fun
One Piece toys and decorations,
and a pirate ship bed of his own.
His room right now is sort of like what
his mom and I wanted his room to be.
So this would be a good opportunity
for him to make his room his own.
with only
48 hours to transform his room
from top to bottom and three flights
of stairs to bring everything up,
every second counted.
You got to get this and this.
Up there.
Assuming we could fit
the pieces inside their apartment.
That was a close one.
Literally.
From there, we drilled, painted,
hung up and styled the rest of the room
to bring the world of One Piece to life.
for Chet.
Time is running out
and we still had so much to do.
Just in time for the finishing touches.
Chet came home,
but had no idea what he was about to walk into.
Hello?
Surprise.
Hey, Chet.
We're from Netflix.
Okay.
Oh, my.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
They put a whole boat in here.
Oh, my.
Jeez!
There you go.
So much One Piece!
This is insane.
Hello.
This is Chester
coming in from the straw hat crew.
I feel like I'm on the ship right now.
You wanna try?
and I can now steer myself into sleep.
I feel like Loofie right now.
I had no idea that Netflix was in my house
right now and in my room.
There's so much cool stuff.
We got the magnifying glass.
We got the Going Mary, too.
We even have the chop shop fruit.
And we got the transponder snail.
It’s a full boat,
so now I'm sleeping on a boat.
right now I'm in the crew's quarters.
A spyglass.
A magnifying glass.
and of course, I'm a pirate,
so I have to have treasure.
Of course.
We got the Jolly Roger.
Like a true pirate!
I'm so surprised. I can't even believe it.
Thank you, Netflix!